hey youtubers is Charlie so there's
gonna be my fear The Walking Dead
episode 2 video there's also a bunch of
the stuff that happened tonight in case
you didn't know Wes Craven just died
earlier today he was one of the best
horror writers and directors in the
business if you don't know who he is
he's the one that did Nightmare on Elm
Street he did the Hellraiser movies a
whole bunch other stuff
so everybody's scrape your fingernails
on a chalkboard and think of him fondly
he's responsible for some of the
earliest nightmares that I ever had some
of my most beautiful nightmares so what
I'm going to do is my top five moments
from the episode just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet here
we go starting with number five Alicia
goes after Matt as predicted he's total
Walker babe but they definitely made us
wait to find out what was going on we
just we hear him wheezing before they
slam to the title sequence
suspense and jump-scares are like two of
the biggest devices that horror stories
use we really didn't find out till
Travis started poking around at him that
he got bit so he's definitely going to
turn it's just a matter of time and if
it's not clear Alicia's one of the few
people that has no idea what's going on
with the Walker virus so that's why
she's so confused over why people want
her to stay away from Matt one of my
favorite lines from the episode though
is when she says if he has it then I
have it which kind of throws forward to
the main show because in the main show
they find out that everyone already has
the Walker virus like if you're confused
about the mechanics of how you turn into
a walker everyone has the virus
you turn whenever you die so when you
get bitten you don't automatically turn
you turn because the walkers that bite
you transmit a bunch of really bad
bacteria that give you really bad
infection you get sepsis and it causes
you to die much quicker moving on to
number four juxtaposing the craziness of
what's going on in the city with the
quiet in the suburbs so we throw to
Chris who's ignoring everyone's phone
calls there riding the bus into the city
he's heading into protest territory but
in the suburbs they get back to their
house and their neighbors are like
setting up for their kids birthday and
everything is business as usual you know
Nick starts to freak out because it's
like how come nobody's talking about it
no one's talking about on the radio
nobody in their neighborhood seems to
know what's going on Nick also gets a
really important line when he says he's
entering a world of [ __ ] now he's
talking about going into heroin
withdrawal but obviously that's a
metaphor for everything just going to
[ __ ] in Los Angeles the entire city
is entering a world of [ __ ] moving out
to number three Matt versus Knicks
descent into a world of [ __ ] one of my
favorite things about this week's
episode was the way they juxtaposed what
was going on with Matt and what was
going on with Nick like they both
started wheezing at a certain point so
naturally they just want you to feel
like Nick might slowly be turning but
he's not he's actually withdrawing from
heroin that's why he looks like crap but
it's funny how heroin withdrawal looks
exactly like turning into a walker think
about that the next time you do drugs I
feel like The Walking Dead is a great
anti-drug PSA this this is what you turn
into because Nick totally understands
what's going on and wants to keep Alicia
from going back to get Matt it sounded
like he was acting a little bit whenever
he started to spit up like whenever it
looked like he started to foam at the
mouth
he's got a nice stash of oxy right now
but he should be good for a while but he
did he did actually say what happens
when this runs out like he will have to
go through full withdrawal at a certain
point if you ever watched lost it's kind
of like Charlie on loss whenever he was
coming down off a heroin I'm interested
to see how they deal with that Walker
across the street it looks like that
lady got away but she didn't kill the
Walker so the Walker is probably gonna
come across the street look for them now
that'll probably be the tipping point
for Alicia when she'll start to realize
what's going on she'll prior to see Matt
is a full Walker before it like clicks
in her head isn't it funny how Nick in
the first episode was like I'm the
screw-up but now he is suddenly like one
of the smartest people on the show he
and Tobias they definitely know their
[ __ ] on to number two meet the Salazar's
in this city the situation in the city
starts to blow up so Travis Liza and
Chris make a run for it but they can't
get out so they just they duck into the
barber shop the Salazar is our main cast
so they're actually going to be pretty
big in this season's story if there were
any potential governors that would rise
up it looks like Daniel might be one of
them he has that look about him one of
my favorite things about their run out
of the city though was Eliza looking at
the street and seeing the tarp blow off
that body I would just I kept waiting
for the body to rise up but it hasn't
happened yet we did see one of the cops
shoot another Walker walking towards it
but it wasn't like a full-on dead person
rising up after being shot like 20 times
that's really what it takes for the
Dumbo's to realize what's going on like
the people that just don't believe no
matter what you tell them so of course
moving on to my number
moment Kim Dickens smashing the hell out
of the principal Walker she's at the de
facto Michonne to the show until someone
more badass comes along I think the
reason they gave her that visceral kill
like just smashing his head and over and
over with the fire extinguisher is to
let you know that she's not going to be
like some wilting flower if you remember
Carol Pelletier from the first couple
seasons of walking dead but before II
died she was kind of stuck inside her
shell but in the last couple of seasons
she's really come into her own she's
like Rambo Carol now this Madison
takedown is like the show telling you
that Kim Dickens character is going to
be a badass from the beginning Madison
is not going to be a TV show Andrea and
it looks like Liza isn't going to be
either we just met the Salazar so we
really don't know what's going on with
them but it definitely looks like the
father is going to be a force to reckon
with if you remember the story of the
governor he actually didn't start out as
the governor in the comic books
it was his brother that was the governor
he was just like a normal guy before the
apocalypse before his family died it
wasn't till the apocalypse and what
happened after that he took on the
governor persona became like the
fearsome governor that we know from the
TV show in the comics so just keep your
eyes peeled to see if anybody is gonna
get that type of arc I mean they're not
going to do a governor type character
but think about the arc that he gets you
know normal man nothing special about
him the apocalypse hits and suddenly he
turns into this really big deal let me
know that what was your favorite moment
from the episode and who do you think is
gonna get the next badass Walker kill I
feel like we need to see a walker kill
inside the city like with Travis's group
at the barbershop but in case you guys
didn't know next week the shows on break
episode 3 won't air for two weeks now I
know that sounds weird there's only six
episodes in the season why are they
taking a week break after the second
episode so AMC is probably just trying
to avoid like a log jam with the MTV
VMAs it'd be like trying to premiere a
show during the Superbowl like while the
Superbowl is going on I mean nobody on
the planet would be watching it real
quick reminder new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video now I'm going to do a Q&A
tomorrow and a game of Thrones bonus
video so keep your eyes peeled for that
there will be a new round of the game of
Thrones giveaway whenever I post that
game of Thrones video in case you guys
are catching up or you haven't seen it
yet you can click here for my fear The
Walking Dead episode 1 video and
you can click here for my latest Game of
Thrones video thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow